(house band flourishing)
- Welcome back, y'all.
We are here with Marcus
Scribner from grown-ish.
Give it up.
(audience cheering)
So, before the break, Marcus
told us he was an expert.
That's right, an expert
at naming dog breeds.
I love dogs as well.
Not feeling confident about this,
but now it is time for game
we are calling, That's Hot, Dog!
♪ That's Hot Dog! ♪
- Of course you made
it country. I love it.
All right, let's get a host in here.
Lord, are you there?
- [God] I am here, Kelly.
How you doing girl?
- I'm so good. God loves our show.
- [God] How's your eyeball doing?
- Dude, I, God I never
done it, but it hurts.
- [God] You got that sexy eye perfume.
A little surprise for your eyes.
That's what I'm talking about.
- My right eye smells really good.
- [God] And how you doing Marcus?
Good to see you.
- I'm doing fantastic, God.
- [God] Here's what's
happening with this game.
Now I'm gonna show you a photo
of a very attractive dog.
- Okay.
- You'll see what I mean.
But all you have to do is hit your button
and be the first to name
the breed of the dog.
That's it.
That's what we came up with today.
Now if you're wrong, the
other person can steal, okay?
Now, if Marcus wins, his photo will be
ceremoniously mounted on The Chicks Wall
of Champs who beat Kelly Clarkson.
- Yes.
- [God] That's what I'm talking about.
- Your distinguished honor.
- [God] And you better watch out,
'cause that wall is filling up fast,
if you look over there.
- All right, God.
- [God] Okay.
And you know my name
spelled backwards is dog.
Okay, let's go. Here we go.
Okay, let's see a photo of the first dog.
- Okay.
(buzzer beeping)
- Golden retriever.
- [God] It is a golden retriever.
(audience cheering)
- Thank God.
- [God] That's right.
- I would have
gotten it wrong.
- [God] My favorite golden
retriever was Air Bud,
and that they made 35 of them damn movies.
- Oh, Air Bud.
- [God] 35 of them damn movies.
- Love that one.
- Very famous.
Okay, here's the next dog.
Here's the next hot dog, take a look.
(buzzer beeping)
- I know that one.
- French bulldog.
- Yeah.
- [God] It is a French Bulldog.
It is Tank, the French Bulldog.
- Tank.
- With his rainbow glasses.
- [God] That's right.
- I love the glamour shot.
That's awesome.
- [God] Doing little wee wee,
a little wee wee on the carpet.
Okay, here's the next dog.
(buzzer beeping)
- Oh, gosh, is it working?
- Oh, standard poodle.
- [God] It is a poodle.
It is Noodle, the poodle.
- Noodle The poodle.
- [God] That's Noodle
the poodle right there.
- I'm just blinking right away.
- [God] Not a lot of
words rhyme with poodle.
I guess there's caboodle.
- Noodle,
the poodle.
There's canoodle the poodle.
But that's something else entirely.
Okay, here's the next dog.
(buzzers beeping)
- Chocolate lab.
- It is a chocolate lab.
That is Otis.
- I feel like
I'm hitting my button.
- [God] Otis, the chocolate lab.
- I feel like I'm hitting my button
like a millisecond after him.
- I'm just, I don't -
- He's young!
- I don't even see the
dog, I'm just going.
- [God] You feel like
you're hittin' that button.
Well feelin' and doin'
ain't the same thing, so.
Let's try again, Kelly.
You feel Like you're
winning too, don't ya?
- I don't, I don't.
- Wow, wow.
- [God] All right, here's the next dog.
- God is a little feisty.
- Here's the next dog.
- Oh, that's a husky.
- [God] It is a Siberian Husky.
That's beautiful Slick.
- All right.
- Yes.
- [God] You know, the Siberian Husky,
that's the only breed that
can alter their metabolism.
I wish I could do that.
- God, me too.
- [God] I know. You know what I'm saying?
Here's the next dog right here.
- You're just hitting it!
And I know what that is.
- Is that a Weimaraner?
- Yes it is.
- [God] It is a Weimaraner.
- He's gotta, he's hitting it
before the (bleeping) picture shows.
(air horn sounding)
- Uh-oh, that means
it's time for our last question.
- Oh man.
- Okay, all right.
- [God] And this one is going to be worth
10 points.
(buzzer sounding)
- Wait, wait, what? I didn't.
- [God] That was correct.
No, I'm just playin', I'm just playing.
Okay.
- (Indistinct), is this a chihuahua?
- [God] It is a Chihuahua, that's Clive
number five, the Chihuahua.
That's the end of our game.
And you just won, son.
- I didn't even know you
were putting the picture up.
It's fine, it's fine.
- I'm like, just -
- I'm so happy for you, Marcus.
- Thank you.
- And because Marcus is so great
and knows his dogs, his photo will be
put up on The Chicks Wall of Champs,
who beat Kelly Clarkson.
(audience applauding)
- Oh I feel so honored Kelly.
- You should.
- Thank you.
- It's such an honor.
- It was an excellent game.
- Thank you, thank you, yeah.
- Excellent game.